[Music]
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed
hey babe girl
she's been living in her hey babe world
hey babe
look at that
gotcha bang even though we told you last
week that he was coming on
joel is here that's it
mr brian quit akaq is here so we have we
have uh quote unquote really never had a
guess we had we did a live podcast a
couple months ago and we had the girl
with the guinness book of records
biggest mouth on
and also the [ __ ] queen the [ __ ] queen
who was a girl same woman no okay
because that's a yeah yeah yeah
one girl with the biggest mouth guinness
book world records and then a woman came
on from the crowd called herself the
[ __ ] queen told a very amazing [ __ ]
story uh that was kind of like epic she
was at her boyfriend's family's house
and she had the [ __ ] and she was
embarrassed to go into the bathroom so
she went into his bedroom [ __ ] in a
shoebox
put it in a bag and then walked it out
in front of them and took it to the
garbage like
yeah so those were our guests i [ __ ] in
an alleyway once you did yeah i was at a
i was dating a girl in manhattan and she
had like one of those apartment that's
just an apartment with a bathroom
you know it was early goings yes and i
was like i had to go so i was like well
i gotta run out to my car so i went out
and i and i took a [ __ ] like like an
animate wait wait wait in an alleyway
wait
starbucks
no no no i was like
on the upper east side it was in the 50s
i don't know i didn't know the
neighborhood i really had to go
and i just went out and squatting would
you use your toilet paper well that's a
great question wow oh why boxes wow
oh so and then you then you left your
boxes yeah it's abandoned and then you
went back it's actually a great idea
though yeah it really honestly it's
almost like your bear grylls i would
have used my socks i think yeah if i was
in that situation i mean again i'm not i
was in that situation but i think if i
had i would use my socks i didn't think
the socks would be enough and i didn't
want to run out of fabric and then i
need to find the second choice we were
in ankle socks uh no
no they were
they were pull upside that's the other
thing too like you'll you'll notice
missing socks yeah yeah you're not
because sometimes joe boxer had like
really long box of shirts banana
republic banana probably shut up wow
somebody's been doing well for a long
time no no no no no when we go on tour
we um you know we hit these uh we hit
these outlets where you can get like
three for twenty dollars
wait a minute you [ __ ] in the alley when
you were already on the show uh this was
no you know what no it was before it
actually yeah yeah i was gonna say holy
[ __ ] yeah
that'd be a funny thing is that
but that's the sale you walk into any
any banana republic in the land and yeah
you get that deal on the you know oh 100
well there was in my where i used to
live in bay ridge there was a banana
republic uh factory like 86th street yes
86 the banana republic factory where i
mean it was like
santa claus prices you could get a shirt
like a beautiful banana republic
button-down shirt for like seven dollars
slightly out of season that's all that's
all it was well maybe a regular i don't
know
why it's more like marshalls right
irregular yeah yeah yeah i have an
irregular body so for me the irregular
prices always work for me because i have
been my body is very irregular uh but
know what they call a banana public
factory that's just a nod to the young
kids in the factory of making the
clothes that's it yeah shut up banana
what is a banana republic i don't know
oh it's it's a banana republic is
basically an illegitimate regime like in
uh like uh
yeah it's like that's what they put it's
like a dictator takes over an island
like let's use cuba for example like a
kangaroo court kangaroo but
government-wise yeah banana republic oh
but so why would they name their
prestigious clothing line then yeah
it sounds cool well they came in and
just took over the mall they took over
the mall yeah they came in and just took
over men's fashion that could be it
that's what it is
here's some examples of banana republic
bangladesh botswana costa rica guatemala
honduras nicaragua nigeria panama all
banana republic locations go check out
some of the prices
wait that's a different definition than
what i gave you because you're saying a
small name this is saying
yeah noun depended on one crop or the
influx of a foreign capital
why is that derogatory a small nation
yeah
spanish
bananas depending on one crop or the
influx of a farm you know that bananas
you know like banana the whole game in
bananas like companies like dole
and whoever else makes bananas chiquita
they
it's a dirty dirty game what they do
like they're it's a lot of i think a lot
of people get killed oh it's like
diamonds yes i think it's a very blood
bananas
yeah so just know every every time you
you know have eat a banana a child's
been maimed well there's also uh can you
can you make that big
like an interesting thing about bananas
and i'm not gonna get this exactly right
but like just try it the one the bananas
that we know and love are like are like
a human-made thing like we've bananas
there's a spectrum of bananas and we
have humans have basically wiped them
wiped all of the bananas out because we
like the taste of this one and we're
always
like
a sea hairs away from losing bananas
because if one but like if bananas get
sick
like if there's a banana disease it will
kill the entire banana crop around the
world should we start putting mass on
the bananas wow possibly what should we
do yeah it's a frustration
bananas are endangered are they and
they're radioactive homeless pimp has
just pulled out that bananas are
actually radioactive
it's well known it's well known that
bananas contain large amounts of
potassium right good for all sorts of
important bodily functions
what is you could use a banana in that
alleyway cute that's might have been
your issue
not enough binding right it's binding
what is less well known is that a small
proportion of that potassium is the
unstable radioactive isotope potassium
40 which is sliding down your throat
alongside the regular potassium every
time you chow down on the infamous bent
fruit so in other words you're
swallowing a little bit of radiation
every time you eat a
banana which is one of those things
though where it's like there's plastic
and everything everything is going to
give you cancer there's rocket fuel and
breast milk rockefeller let me figure
that out we figured that out on the last
episode every every uh every america
especially american women now when
they're breastfeeding there's a small
amount of rocket fuel
because of the milk
what is what did we find out uh factory
leaking chemicals into the crops over
the years yeah
yeah so so it's pretty disgusting yeah
yeah banana peels are great for skin i
wasn't breastfed
and i'm grateful for it really yeah yeah
just never wanna i want to go to the
grave knowing i never sucked on my mom's
teeth
i know it's natural and all but you hit
a certain age and it's not natural it's
not natural i don't think i did like the
kid in the uh
in that crying game game of thrones
like 17. oh yeah the uh and then that's
the one they threw with the mother out
door door yeah yeah throw them in the
moon door yeah i i'm i think i was not
breastfed either because my mom was a
working girl so she didn't have time to
breastfeed my children now are not are
not bra we're not breastfed have you uh
you've seen breastfeeding in the wild uh
of course right probably everybody has
what do you mean like an animal
breastfeeding or a human oh no no no no
no what i meant was like on the
statement
like the mall yeah yeah oh yeah yeah
all good natural everything all that
stuff i don't agree with no
i don't agree with it but i was gonna
say sometimes sometimes
they they like it's usually they they
it's a discreet thing but sometimes it's
not no and i've seen literal i've seen
the milk like the the drippings coming
out the drippy nip and i've seen like
all the old i seen behind the curtain
right
and uh to put the person was not phased
and i i understand that that's the way
they live their life and they're not
going to take it you know they're not
going to
stop there there's steam rolling through
motherhood and i understand it but i was
taken back to see to see a nipple like
that i got a friend who does maintenance
at jfk airport and at jfk airport they
have breastfeeding pods that i agree
with he said okay which i agree with too
yeah he said
daily multiple times a day i have to go
in there and clean [ __ ] out of the pots
people go in there and jerk off every
single day men go into those
breastfeeding pods when no one's looking
and masturbating there constantly it's a
plague of jfk so they they're
considering getting rid of the
breastfeeding pods because guys won't
stop jerking off in there guys ruin
everything ruin everything how could you
imagine you're that guy i mean how do
you i get i get weirded out stepping
back out of a bathroom stall in a public
restroom when there's people waiting and
i'm just like sorry you know i just feel
weird a guy's gonna slink out of there
and close the door are you gonna see him
coming out of the breast well because
because in an effort to protect the
woman's i guess whatever embarrassment
or i don't know they put them in like
locations where like you don't even know
they're there kind of thing it's like in
the corner of like an abandoned terminal
so it's easy to kind of get in you know
yeah they're like you're right they're
like off the beaten path yeah it's like
in the shadows it's not like next to the
starbucks you know so yeah but also
who's the guy that's like not only am i
gonna do this i'm spraying the walls
well that's that's what i thought it was
like why do you need to at least just do
it into your belly go in there with a
wet wipe it's not an issue but it's
something about like a defiance where
they public shorts bananas
i love the idea of like of like some guy
sitting at home like he he spent years
uh like mopping the porn boots in times
square and then he got obsolete as time
spread cleaned up and then one day his
phone rings and he's like we need you
well there's only one man for the job
and he's like he's like hello he's like
we need you
and then he's pulled out of retirement
to go
well i haven't mopped up coming forward
he's like do you still have it he opens
a closet there's a broom there with a
golden handle
he's caked up he just comes the mop is
just like just a hard thing he's pushing
all right what's up everybody december
17th and 18th i will be at the west palm
beach improv tickets are almost sold out
so go there i'm coming to florida
freedom baby i love it december 26 to
the 31st co-headlining with salvo cano
sally babes you're gonna have a great
time we'll be in texas missouri and ohio
get the tickets and then chrissy
theaters everybody hashtag cte the tour
begins january 29th the borgata go check
out all the cities january 14th 15th
we're gonna be in austin texas too at
the vulcan gas company we're gonna have
a good good time so go to
christycomedy.com also patreon.com
christy comedy for all the content the
chris and eddie show we just put out is
fantastic and tt jerry's bucket list
show at patreon.com says christy comedy
i mean if you want to feel good for the
holidays just watch this show because
the one that we're putting out
this week is amazing we bought tt a car
and it's just you're going to cry you're
going to jerk off it's good it's good
you're going to laugh and come
patreon.com christy comedy christy
comedy.com for tickets listen if you're
looking for a last-minute christmas gift
buy someone tickets to the shows why the
hell not i would like to receive that my
mother bought me tickets to my own shelf
because she forgot that it was christmas
she forgot about her only child all
right man i want to eat so bad i want
i'm going to eat whole wheat pizza
december 10th in boston the shovel year
theater december 11th at the borgata
kind of hometown thing atlantic city new
jersey there's only a few tickets left
for boston ac please get those to come
out december 26 dallas december 27 san
antonio december 28th sugarland aka
houston december 29th st louis december
30th columbus and new year's eve
december 31st cincinnati all those are
with chris d and then my new dates that
just went up january 14th in des moines
january 15th in indianapolis january
16th in cleveland january 29th at
foxwoods in connecticut we are adding a
show the first one is basically sold out
february 19th in washington dc slash
tysons virginia to be announced very
quickly uh next week or this coming week
i will be announcing just so keep a
heads up san diego los angeles
burlington vermont detroit pittsburgh
albany madison and chicago all tickets
savolcano comedy.com uh more cities
being announced i mean it's a mouthful
but i just i need you guys to come out
and see me because it's been so long and
we need to laugh and uh this is casey
jost everybody the earth is flat
um and then my friend too i have another
friend who works we've talked about
before who works on the airlines loading
baggage he said daily
he has to they have to because you put
your bags through and then they scan
them again before they go through it
they always do a double we don't see
that part
daily he has to take they're a a live
animal usually a chicken or a rooster
in a suitcase that's stuffed in on
flights to certain locations wow he's
like it happens every day we have to
open up a suitcase and let a live
rooster out and let it fly out
on the tarmac
you know that's why when you come from
the country and they give you that thing
to fill out yeah and there's always that
box like do you have livestock yeah it's
like who's got livestream who's got
livestock
but people do and then if you imagine
you have the livestock if you have the
livestock you're not checking the
livestock box yeah you're trying to get
through yeah so no one's gonna check yes
i have lost dude when you know it's
knowing someone who works at behind the
scenes at an airline is like knowing a
doctor like doctors they carry around a
lot of stress because they know all the
ways that you can die or the sicknesses
they've seen things like somebody has a
light cough and then they're dead
going on an airline knowing i know these
he's will never fly because he's like
there are so many ways to get things
onto an airplane like bombs and guns
onto an airplane that is so like an
idiot could do it it you never would go
through tsa he said all you got to do is
like go get a job uh you know the food
he said the food when they load the food
onto the plane none of that is checked
none of that is checked at all he said
you want to you could put a bomb in a
turkey club maybe you dropped this audio
yeah
this has been hey
this is huge in cabal are you kidding me
this kills in the caliphate um so
so oh you're gonna freak me i i don't
like to fly as it is no he was like dude
he's like i i you know it doesn't happen
he's like but it's just
none of this stuff is checked he said
also the trucks the trucks that come in
they just get let in by a security guard
like some guy who doesn't give a [ __ ]
about his job like the movies when the
guy buys the fake security guard outfit
and just lets him right in just let him
write it
he said so like everybody nobody who who
wants to do a terrorist attack was going
through tsa that's little league [ __ ]
right they go through the back doors
which are just not manned yeah we're
over on the front where they're like
take off shoes yeah but do you but like
if even if they i mean the days
like if a gun snuck onto a plane though
the days have taken over planes are over
right nobody's gonna allow that anymore
i don't think you can get even allegedly
i heard that you can't even get into the
cockpit right unless not even the flight
attendants can get in they have to open
it from the inside they got to do like
this and i think it's probably also just
agreed upon i'm not going to let anybody
yeah i'm sorry i'm saying is this just
agreed upon between the pilot and his
flight attendants that if [ __ ] goes down
they're gonna die out there they're
gonna die yeah well i'm even talking
about the people on the plane like after
9 11 like you're just going to assume
they're going to crash you into a
building
a razor blade yeah i'll take my chances
with you hundred percent
i mean the best case scenario is i stop
it and then i'm a hero
and then like clint eastwood makes a
movie about me right that's not bad
those are good odds you know what i mean
yeah that's a good odds people would
want you to please you now yeah
[Laughter]
we were at work the other day
and uh there's this homeless guy in
front of the uh unhoused i don't know
what the [ __ ] people say um but there's
a homely guy in front of 7-11 and he was
hitting people up for change and i
walked up
near him and he didn't ask me for change
and i was like
i was like do i not look like i have
changed and i looked at what i was
wearing and it was ripped jeans and a
20 year old flannel and the beard in the
hair and i was like this [ __ ]
competition yeah i was like this is
pretty [ __ ] so funny he looked he was
like this is my beat buddy yeah i was
like oh that's something why don't you
go back to your own corner yeah yeah i
dude you know what an article i saw the
other day i
that after
2026
every car i think congress just passed
this that's how i know i have dirtbag
friends every car wants to uh is legally
going to have to have a breathalyzer in
it that you can't start the car unless
your blood alcohol level is below the
legal limit and my friends were like
this is [ __ ] what if there's a
forest fire and i need to start my car
and i die in the fire i was like you
guys are alcoholic dirtbags a forest
fire we live in queens i'd love to see
i'd love to see that congressional
hearing where they're trying to pass
that and suddenly the guy from
patty
uh your honor if i may
let's just say i'm in a forest yeah and
and the fire is burning i got to stop my
car to drive away but i had it but he
said but i had a few drinks because i'm
i'm at home but then the fire li then
the trees light on fire am i just
supposed to die okay what if yeah but
that's true though what's a good point
what if i'm drinking wine at home yeah
you know it's a nice night and then all
of a sudden i have checked pain in my
chest or someone needs to go to and i
gotta jump in my car to take them now
the car is not gonna start you i don't
think you can't buy it self-drive
no they send this
congress said google it google congress
2026 they're really breathalyzer in the
car i mean it's it's getting they're
just trying to make cars obsolete that's
what that's what it is yeah it's just
this rush to i know my friends like more
mandates
just like yelling yeah new mandate to
car makers yeah here we go congress has
created its new requirement for order
makers high-tech way to keep drunken
people from driving cars yep they go
road yeah i mean let's be honest it's
i mean it's a good idea it's gonna it's
gonna save a lot of innocent lives it
will uh but it'll cause a lot of
inconvenience and so now what you gotta
do is you gotta have two buckets yeah
you gotta have a bucket and you gotta
weigh them
the inconvenience bucket and the death
bucket yeah can you get a cough counter
on salad by the way so i started taking
a new medication yeah
and the medication and the uh the number
one side effect is a cough and boy is it
true
and uh i'm sorry i've been apologizing
no everyone i've kept talking about for
the last two weeks because i once it
flares up i cough every 30 seconds and i
cannot imagine we're not in the radio
show here so i don't have a cough button
i can't imagine what you're all going
through and what the listeners are going
through and i just want to tell you that
if you are listening and you hear my
coughs if you are listening and we know
that you are yeah
uh you know i don't want to be on
medication but uh but sometimes you have
to sometimes you just have to be in this
day and age you have to be and so i take
the coffee we're also on estrogen
therapy yes what's going on
as we all are i know i should probably
throw a lozenge in my mouth no it's fine
i was just kidding around it doesn't but
yeah all right i um yeah
you were coming off a [ __ ] still you you
[ __ ] your pants because someone else
[ __ ] that you no you were talking about
the guest your guest the woman that
[ __ ] her pants right but my point
being we've never had a true in-house
in-studio guest that was like on the fly
at the live show so i mean you guys are
killing it taking nothing away from them
i would like to just say it's an honor
to have you as our
first guest nice yeah it was really
going to be you are ari shafir so
right yeah
we might have better stories than me but
yeah yeah this is good i think this is
right no this is good yeah so
i mean i feel like too like even having
a guest like we should have prepared
some fun guest questions but we did it
yeah it's awesome i can ask the question
i always ask yeah do you have any ghost
stories he loves this [ __ ] uh i i do not
i my my grandmother told the story about
a ghost pulling her hair
uh years ago but i don't i don't believe
in i don't know i got a laugh
thank
you
yeah you know my grandmother was you
know crazy but i i i don't believe it
you don't why don't you believe i mean
it's just like look i would love to see
i would love to see a ghost people like
if i if i am in spooky places or scary
places where i'm like this feels weird i
do this switch in my head where i'm like
i want to see a ghost because then
that's evidence that there's an
afterlife like that's how i see it so i
would [ __ ] never be scared to see a
ghost i'd be like this is [ __ ]
awesome this means that i go on after
death but i but there's just zero zero
we should have done a ouija board today
together we should have did a ouija
board i'm not afraid of any of it i
would have done it i don't care devils
all that stuff it doesn't i don't think
any of it goes down speaking of spooky
and stuff do you do you do haunted
houses haunted houses yeah do you do
that i did a i just did a haunted um i
just did i just did a haunted train in
um in um uh new hope pennsylvania a
haunted train first of all we did this
haunted train we did steam locomotive
steam local new home pennsylvania it was
pretty awesome yeah you walk into the
train so i we thought the train station
at the bridge between lambertsville and
new hope here it is okay that's it whoa
big time someone does a lot of shopping
there's a lot
[Laughter]
so we had a little kid train there's a
little kid train there called the
spookily train it's like you know it
literally if if the people from new hope
who we had a great time as a family
there but i mean it was a little
ridiculous you had a woman an elderly
woman walking up and down a train a
steam locomotive at so loud reading a
story from a book with a full mask on
and no microphone i mean my kids
couldn't care no child on that train
cared at all she was trying to tell a
scary story and not miked with a mask on
in pure daylight no so she would start
telling the story and then go all the
way down the train car and then come
back my kids missed 80 of what she said
right because she was all the way down
there right so we were like whatever but
we still had a good time but then
the adults went on we had somebody watch
the kids the adults we went on the
nighttime like scary haunted train and
we thought it was just gonna we thought
we were just gonna get on a train uh you
know and it was gonna be smoke and fog
and scary music and maybe people jump
out of the woods could go deep into the
woods but what and that eventually did
get to that but you go into the train
and there's some guy who's a you know
regular guy and you can't see because
only calling up two or what you could
only walk in with your party so if it
was two four or five whatever but once
you go in you can't see what's going on
so the guy comes out normal he goes how
many in your party and we were like two
he goes oh great right this way and then
we step into a compartment and then he
slams the door
i was like holy [ __ ] he just turns on
you yeah and then the lights immediately
go out i like immediately go out like
full dark and then another door in front
of you opens like a huge uh like freight
train we're on a freight train freight
train door opens and it's you know
you're in now a full haunted house where
he goes you know it's just like all
ghouls and everything you have to walk
through they're up in your face they got
knives they're cutting off your fingers
like literally terrifying i was like oh
my god and you keep walking through
walking through walking through and
you're like i can't do this for an
entire train and then you get to one you
see like light and then you see another
worker is at the end and he's like how
many in your party like you like and
then you go on to the actual train and
then you sit down and then what they do
is they give you drinks and you know you
know adult theme you know it's pretty
cool and you sit and you're like oh fine
that at least we're not gonna be scared
it's just gonna be fun through the woods
they got like halloween lights they're
playing like you know thriller and stuff
and then the lights go out on the train
and fog because we we sat in the middle
of the train so i'm like if anyone's
coming i want to go to this because i
said if anybody's coming from the front
of the back i told my girl i said we're
not we won't be scared because if they
do pull some [ __ ] and hijinks we would
know whatever way they come from by the
time we get to the middle we know but
then fog fills the entire train you
can't i could you can't see who's next
to you so then it's and then they just
start coming out
with crazy [ __ ] and you're literally
terrified for 45 minutes sitting on that
goddamn track i can't do it there's
there's that new thing now it's like
that next level [ __ ] uh that
if you see it there's like one in every
city now where it's like you sign a
waiver and you go in alone one of them's
full nude
oh the the halloween house yeah yeah
fully you know you gotta go nude i think
you have to be naked workers you want to
be very vulnerable but then another one
and another one there is nudity in it so
you sign this waiver you step in it is
pitch black and you go through a loan
and they're allowed to you're signing it
that they're allowed to physically rough
you up too
no and you go through and it's like like
an hour long they say no one like not a
lot of people can make it through and
people in every room it's insane like
people will throw you against the wall
yeah i did like put a knife to your
throat you did that yeah i did yeah if
you don't want to get touched they put a
red x on your head so the actors know
not to touch well no i did the thing
with the red x but that was just like a
regular thing and i'm such a puss that
every time someone came in the room i
was like
that's right that's right yeah
because one time i was in one i don't
like to go but as long as i go and i
have a wall of people around me and
another thing i do is i close my eyes
because of halloween horror we did it in
um where you loved loved to go in
universal yes yeah yeah i had a wall of
people around me i was in the center but
i would just keep my head down and hold
the friends down and keep my head down
and close my eyes so i don't see
anything because i can't take the
anticipation of someone gonna grab me i
just can't talk so i would go red x red
x but then one time i was in one and uh
it was before i was on television right
or before i was in the public and one of
the guys came out and he was in the room
and he and he was walking he had a black
master and he went sal
and i freaked out i was like what the
[ __ ] and i just ran out an exit door
behind how did they know and i just ran
out into like it was in like a literally
in like a field
and uh then he came out afterwards he
pulled over his mess it was one of my
old bar patrons
yeah yeah listen yeah do you everybody
and their mother is selling stuff online
these days oh baby that's why ship
station is so important that's what it
is because if you got you know you got
to keep up with your shipping keep up
with your orders ship station makes it
easy to use the hassle of shipping it
takes the hassle of shipping out of
holiday orders right out the window
shipstation does it for you yeah you got
inventory to manage orders to fill and a
growing list of stressed out customers
checking in twice a day wondering
whether those last minute gifts are
going to arrive yeah ship station the
hassle of shipping melts away changing
your shipping solution can seem daunting
but with the holidays here now's the
time to think about making a change
change is good babe change is good ship
station works with all major carriers
international and local and local
including fedex uh united states postal
service and ups you even get access to
discounted rates that are usually
reserved only for fortune 500 companies
no big shots yeah no wonder 98 of
companies that use shipstation for a
year keep using it so those other two
percent are [ __ ] i don't like going
to the post office there i said it i
don't want to do it you just this is it
this is the post office in your house
yeah next the freaking the son of sam
worked at the post office next year you
know i got to get killed by the sun and
sam i'll use ships that's exactly right
make this holiday season a little
brighter
with ship station use our offer code hey
babe to get 60 day free trial that's two
months to you and me just enough time to
handle the holiday rush just go to
shipstation.comshipshipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top and
enter code hey babe ship station
make ship happen this is better help and
better help we do the ads but
we talk about better help more than
anyone else just on the podcast before
we do the ads i talk i don't know the
better how people watch the podcast yeah
but if you do we talk about better help
on the podcast so maybe just bump up the
price a little bit alright yeah and i
talked to one of your licensed health
professionals twice a week
so
so better help i can tell you it's this
podcast sponsor i better help and it's
it sponsors my mental health because i
use it i love it it's available for
clients worldwide you can log into your
account anytime send a message to your
counselor any time it's not a crisis
line no you do not talk with a licensed
professional
it's professional counseling done
securely online i love it um better help
it's it's the best and you guys can get
a great discount
yep if you just go to betterhelp.com
hey babe that's better help h-e-l-p
betterhelp.com hey babe you get 10 off
your first month promo code hey babe i
did i did uh uh because i love key west
it's like my favorite place and they
have a great because i like haunted like
all the mythology of ghosts i i [ __ ]
love so they have these haunted tours in
key west where you get in it's like a
trolley and they take you around and you
get boozed up you smoke a little weed
you get on it's [ __ ] great and the
it's a trolley made up to look like a
hearse and the person is that's giving
the tour is dressed like a ghost and is
in um uh character and they're like i
was uh you know a pirate and then they
given it's a great tour and i've
probably done it five times so i did it
this couple of months back and i got
this one woman and we were hammered and
we're on there and it's like the entire
time all she talked about was slavery in
key west and how and how the ghosts of
slaves come up and it was like and i had
been building it up to like jiggy and
brian johnson i was like guys it's so
much fun we're gonna get hammered they
go and they talk about this one guy that
[ __ ] the dead body there's a haunted
doll there's a haunted doll like oh my
god old pirate [ __ ] we get in it was a
100 slave reaction the entire time
and it's just like and it's just like
the energy just everybody just started
and then by the end and then she pulls
up to a a slave graveyard and she gets
out with a cane which i've never seen
before and she just go starts going
here's a grave
here's a grave
here's a grave slave grave slave grave
what that's a grave and we're all
sitting there watching around the thing
and we're just like
sorry guys like it was the biggest one
we got off it and we just went to bed
and it was like eleven o'clock on the
website you checked the website it's
probably new management no management
yeah it was [ __ ] something i was like
this is not why i'm on vacation
so there was this place i don't know it
still exists but it was the place that
you hoped that you would go to on a
class trip in grammar school it's called
wild west city okay
no it's like it was in jersey it was a
ride from here maybe an hour or two so
it was close i don't remember where it
was there we see commercials and
everything look wild west city city
cities running wild is this it yeah
that's it yeah so if that's it oh my god
i haven't laid eyes on it and since i'm
a little kid and it was made up to look
like an old wild west town it's all dirt
it had all the stores and literally it
was like this immersive town okay you
would go there and you we got cowboy
hats and i would get the best strap with
the guns and spurs everyone
everyone loved it
two stories off the hill
so the big the big big things of the day
right were
a a wild west showdown happens dead in
the center of town amazing and you know
you wait for it all day you like going
in and out of saloons you're buying
stuff you're eating that you you know
you've seen all this stuff and you feel
like you're in the wild west you do not
see other life because it's it's it's
the it's the road and both sides you you
only see the wild west so it's very
immersive and then at some point static
happens between like somebody and
another cowboy another cowboy and
they're like who you calling whatever
and they shove each other and everyone's
like oh and everyone just gathers around
i love it and then they're like i'll get
let's do a draw and then they do it and
they
shoot like the gun it's a script and the
guy blood and he falls to the ground and
was like ah [ __ ] it's cool it's like
like almost like um medieval times but i
want to go now i want to go it opens in
may of 2022 it's reopening oh let's go
i'm down to do it
we used to do uh field trips with the
listeners yeah
gallagher live right did i ever tell you
that story no i will tell you yeah put
that when he started scolding us we'll
we'll check it out yeah that one so
anyway in this place another highlight
was you get on a stage coach okay and
the stage ghost has a horse it's a real
stage coach and you go through the woods
and it's like a 20-minute stagecoach but
then somewhere in the middle it gets
held up but the thing about it is is
it's all children and they they hold it
up like it's real and they
we loved it but if you think about it in
hindsight they were like the horses pull
up they they jump to the guy that's
driving the train they like they like
hurt him yeah he can't drive the
stagecoach anymore and then like give me
give me your money right now and now you
think i'm playing and they put the gun
in your face everyone's like ah
they completely hijacked the train and
like you think of it now it's it's wild
yeah right
yeah yeah yeah yeah i had the same [ __ ]
going down i put a cowboy stand in my
girlfriend's ass and he was in character
but i was like
so i i remember one year i got this
straw cowboy hat that had like a a white
wrap around it said wild west city and
blue cursive i mean it was like i swear
to god it was like i thought i was hot
[ __ ] it was like i loved west city we
probably went three or four times over
the years of christmas probably never
heard of this and you've never heard of
this either and i've worked in the same
area yeah they see the stagecoach and um
anyway and there was also a locomotive
and that got held up too you couldn't
escape crime at this place wow
so so i got this hat and it was i swear
to you i swear to you you know those
things you remember when you were little
that it was a prized possession the
moment i got it right i wore that thing
i put on my head i wore that thing for
like [ __ ] every moment yeah right and
like like a few days later i was at my
aunt's house on staten island and i got
into a little tussle with my sister
right and uh she's evil you know she was
evil back then and she used to just
fight dirty and i was at my ancestors
and and she she wanted something for me
and i said like we had whatever
disagreement we had and i turned and my
aunt lived in a uh two
floor home and there was one long
staircase that went downstairs i
remember she had this thick brown shag
carpeting like thick like the things
were like this long they look like it's
like a [ __ ] like a snuffalopic or
something right and my sister shoves me
from behind i wasn't looking shoves me
in the back and i went head first i had
the cowboy hat on and i went i went head
first and i tumble sauced down the steps
head over feet head over feet over feet
and then i got to the bottom and it was
one of those steps where it goes this
way for a full staircase and then it
turns for like four steps to go to the
front door so there's a wall at the
bottom of it the wall was stucco it was
like the 80s and they had like they're
not stuck oh yeah
and i went she pushed me from behind i
had no idea what's coming i went head
over head over here and i went
and i slammed into the wall and my arm
got stuck in the stucco and the straw
hat was around my neck
she [ __ ] the hat came right over my
head and got crushed broke over my head
and my arm was in the wall
it was it was right when i got back from
huawei city and she gave you your
iphobia we have to have her on yeah
yeah we we have to get you that hat
again we have to go back
i have the dust remember we bought a
duster we cuz cause for whatever reason
we decided to go stan hope's uh uh super
bowl party in costume you had a big
feather boa yes
and i had like and i bought a cowboy hat
in the duster and i wore it for like 13
hours straight it was great i still have
that there's probably pictures of that
online yeah yeah if you put like us at
stanford anyway but um yeah so that we
have to do this because i mean that that
i can't
when you get to go do things like that
where it's like goes back in time like
like you mentioned medieval times i
think it's the most fun
how can you have more fun than if i
transported you back to the wild west
you're in new jersey
i i slept in that duster i still have
that man
wow
this is at doug stanhope's house yeah
it's in his yard see the bingo sign in
the background oh yeah yeah yeah
dougie stand up there you go hilarious i
love that oh wow look at that cut i got
yeah that's a good haircut
is it the same guy that you've been
using did he couldn't do that that was
like this was like 2013 or something
actually that hair is like that because
i also slept like that and woke up like
that
it was just from 2013.
i think so i think so
i don't get better with you right i won
10 000 on the game that that year
i put on uh
uh money in a super bowl box and i and i
won the halftime it was like seattle
versus somebody else ten thousand that's
good thousand dollars
yeah man i one of my friends won ninety
thousand dollars and they gave it to him
in all cash
well that's when they do the way to get
all off to yeah but i mean 90 000 in
cash is a lot of freaking money yeah
he's gone it's gone now yeah every every
year i win at like other because because
i was a fireman so i that we have the
super bowl thing in the house you know
for points right you know uh in the vios
and and and i'm still in it every year i
win every [ __ ] year like it's my
favorite the guys hate it so [ __ ]
much like the angry texts i get the rich
get richer [ __ ] you
it's the best it's it's i just i just
gave him two thousand points like same
boxes
i don't even care about the money all i
care about is busting their balls yeah
but you also hook them up you tr you get
them all sorts of gifts and stuff yeah i
spend it on them yeah i love it but yeah
those guys well you got them the hockey
machine i just bought them a bubble
hockey machine uh i got on a playstation
new playstation recently i want to get a
bubble hockey machine what's a bubble
hockey machine
you know the the hockey
like like foosball yeah but hockey
hockey players yeah yeah and it's under
a bubble the one i got him has all the
same oh
the super checks there you go right to
the right yeah that one that looks sick
that's fine yeah i got them devils and
rangers oh you could pick the teams you
could pick the teams yeah yeah and you
could even pick what jerseys they wear
home or whey who's
who's logos on the ice so i wanted one
of these i had the one that you bought
it like toys r us yeah as a kid it had
no dome it was just a tabletop one much
cheaper version of that but as a kid it
was like my god and the guys were just
like pieces of plastic with stickers but
like like that but even cheaper um i
wanted one so bad that when i got of age
like a teenager i was gonna buy one and
i priced them and back then
those dome ones i got priced for 700
bucks wow it's not bad there were three
to five thousand up there just now wow
you come a long way maybe the technology
doesn't sound the led lights yeah yeah
yeah yeah all the stuff it's all i think
it's a different everything they have
concussion protocols
[Laughter]
you know pip you always ask everybody
about ghosts and i never there's one
always pimp he's always there he's just
the most interesting part of reality to
me
he thinks that ghost what his opinion is
he's also high a lot always on amazon
there's nothing wrong with that
he thinks that ghosts are a rip in in
like reality right like it's either to
me a dimension rip or the fact that this
is a video game i heard an interesting
theory on ghost once i don't know if
you've ever heard this before but
essentially they were saying like if you
were looking for a scientific reason for
ghosts to hear voices is that the air
the atmosphere has a certain amount of
electromagnetic energy to it and and
much like when you record on tape you
imprint on you know magnetically on tape
that there can be magnetic imprints on
the ionosphere i guess and sometimes you
could encounter the playback of those
that make sense
but why is it always like in the
upstairs room at night
right is that where the ionosphere is is
this weakest well no maybe that's where
you're alone and like paying attention
to your surroundings maybe you're on the
ferry and you're just you hear it but
you're like it's a [ __ ] baby crying
yeah fairy wow
the theory i heard about ghosts um
the most crazy one is that when when
when people pass on
like their spirit inhabits the ghost
what's interesting yeah so the ghost
exists and the spirit goes
no i just was trying to say they have
ghost experience they find this i was
trying to say the thing that everyone
knows
dude my aunt who is a very i think
you're gonna do my aunt who is a ghost
who is been dead for years now my aunt
who is a very normal like as normal as
can be
human being not crazy not like that
wacky aunt none of that she's a normal
lady with a husband and children just
like everybody else just whatever
sees ghosts regularly and it's not out
of her mind and she so the craziest one
is she and this is all uh fact checked
by my aunt my my my my aunt my mom are
one of uh five
their mother their my grandmother was
really sick my grandmother by the way
old school had scarlet fever which whoa
like that's an old-school thing to have
like you had scarlet like the velveteen
rabbit yeah [ __ ] yeah that's how they
killed it right right
and then it became alive for some reason
the velveteen rabbit to scarlet
feminists it might have been smallpox or
something they had to burn the rabbit in
the end they became
famous
literary children's book
yeah she had full scholar fever and so
it's old school whatever it happens and
then my one of my mom's boyfriend said
polio a very old school thing but that's
nothing to do with anything but but
she my aunt was 29 30 at the time
got a call mother their mother was in
the hospital you know in hospice care at
the time got a call from her mother
who was you know intubated at that time
her mother said i just well you know
everything's fine
and um it's everything's gonna be okay
so just tell your sisters everything's
okay
tells wakes up at like two you know
there's walk around 2 30 in the morning
my mom lived upstairs from her goes up
and i was an infant tells her like my
mom just called and said everything's
fine
so i guess like the doctor
it's like she's recovering like they
said everything's fine
so calls my other aunts couple blocks
away
all living like in the same air but
calls them and says mom is fine like
they're like so
full of joy because they genuinely she
got a call from her mother saying it's
i'm fine don't worry about it i'm fine
goes literal you know they're like okay
what are we gonna do go get in a car
this is you know the 80s no cell phones
whatever go start going towards the
hospital hospice wherever she was get
there say we're here to see their mom
and the doctor says oh her body's been
moved to the morgue she passed away
oh my god and so they were like so my
aunt was like she called me from the
afterlife like she called my she dialed
my aunt number collect collections it's
probably rotary too that's the thing
yeah it's harder if you have i guess
it's easier to call to a landline
because it doesn't happen much because
she accepted the charge she accepted it
yeah thank god and verizon has service
everywhere which is shout out verizon
that we're using at the time so so she
so my aunt then was like oh my god
that's what happened must have been what
happened fast forward like five years
later a very very close relative of
my family was dying calls my aunt
with a similar story saying i'm fine
everything she went back to the well she
went back to the wall i swear to god
and then that woman died so is your aunt
possibly just lying to you guys no it's
funny because you started the story by
saying that your aunt's not crazy but
everything you said then only supports
that she's enough she i swear to god no
she she's like my aunt burst into the
room did let us know she had feces on
her face
yeah she's proved to me many times the
earth is flat she's proven it
no but she because the reason why i
would agree with you but the reason why
normal she lives in a bomb shelter
because she is she these people are not
known to be dead yet
and they die
within hours after that
so yeah that's what it is but if if i
experience that once
i don't know how i feel
if i experienced it twice i might be so
shake i might be liable to do something
i might become crazy i might wanna i
don't know what i would do my second
cold phone call from a dead person i
might cut off my own business
as i'm actually i just need something
has to take the place of that i can't
as i'm actually telling these stories
you might be right about her being kind
of wacky because i swear to god
she said that
she said
that she has a letter from santa her
grandfather
she claims that her grandfather who uh
their grandfather who died came to her
when she was in the basement doing
laundry and then her grandfather
disappeared into the washing machine so
she did say that but it was a spiritual
thing and she was like he just vanished
into the washing machine so i guess she
could be a schizophrenic that's on
medicaid shout out whirlpool
yeah
show so i i guess but i don't know you
said at the beginning
they said she has proven to me time and
time again she's a normal person she is
a normal person i mean she would she
took care of me when i was a kid like
nev you know makes like you know is
always there for thanksgiving with the
same dish um
what proves the purse is not crazy she
had the buttered carrots so she's fine
yeah no she makes this string bean
casserole that's phenomenal that's i
could go for a string bean casserole
i've never had a string bean casserole
no i went yesterday
what is the string bean casserole it's
um it smells like a string bacon
it's like a cake they use like cereal
sometimes like they crumble it up and
and amazing and they bake it in like a
baking pan it's it looks like a sheet
cake made of whatever you put in
yesterday yesterday i went to do you
ever go to juicy lucy's on staten island
i went to a drive-in
buck wow that old local sound blaster i
went to juicy lucy's on staten island
shout out if that's
all the cap right yep
shout out we went there and i had i was
a drive-in movie from my daughter's
school and i had a sweet potato
casserole it was one of those things
that was so good i almost took a bite
and launched it at the car next to us
because it was so freaking good so good
at marshmallows reactions and things you
want to cut off your penis if you see a
ghost for the second time you have food
you like it when i salt people yeah yeah
i know sal comes in fully trans one day
it's like i saw a ghost
it finally happened i needed to do this
[Laughter]
so good and like you don't want to let
the person know yeah how good it is how
good it is yeah they don't ask them
anything he's like oh can i get him or
even if he's a lot of those like can i
get a bite
you wouldn't like it no i didn't tell my
six-year-old daughter how good it was i
was like you just eat those disgusting
chicken fingers
no dude babes we deserve to know what
we're putting in our hottie bodies and
why
especially when it comes to something we
take every day which is like a
multivitamin which i've been doing for
20 years
formulated with high quality nutrients
in bioavailable forms your body can
actually use ritual vitamins well that's
who we're talking about ritual which i'm
saying i've been taking a multivitamin
for about 20 years and since ritual came
on board with us yes i tried it out and
they are my new multi now that is ritual
made it traceable which i love high
quality nutrients including vitamin d3
which is very important in the new world
we live in in just two daily pills
you'll always know what nutrients you're
taking and where they come from thanks
to rituals one of a kind visible supply
chain i mean all these places talk about
the supply chain issues not with ritual
it makes healthy habits easy the ritual
pills are not stuck on the port of los
angeles right now yeah okay no but
you're multivitamins that's not the
that's also not the supply chain they're
talking about
where each of the ingredients okay you
know okay i didn't know if you knew i
didn't know
god bless
your multivitamins are delivered to your
door every month with free shipping
always so that's that's the cool thing
about it it's just a it's coming to your
door you don't have to be like i ran out
whatever and you could start snooze or
cancel the subscription anytime so you
don't have to worry about like it
repeating if you don't want it if you
don't love it within your first month
they'll refund you all your money
there's nothing to lose get key
nutrients without the bs ritual is
offering hey babe listeners 10
off during your first three months visit
ritual.com
hey babe to start your ritual today all
right we want to talk to you about keeps
two out of three men are gonna
experience one thing and one thing only
that's hair loss by the time they're 35
more than 50 million men in the us
suffer from male pattern baldness there
are only two fda approved medications
that can prevent hair loss guess who's
offered them guess who offers them both
keep peeps keep it off is a simple
stress-free way to keep your hair
convenient virtual doctor consultations
and medications delivered straight to
your door these are the that's the big
benefit for all these for me too
straight to you straight for your door
discreet you don't have to think about
it it's every three months you don't
leave your home it's low cost treatment
started just 10 bucks a month it keeps
offers generic versions too discrete
packaging proven results whatever it
says mailman comes the door he puts the
pill right in my mouth
prevention is key treatments can take
four to six months to see results so act
fast but guys you guys are listening to
this a lot of guys would women don't get
mad and baldness they could female
pattern baldness
go to keeps if you listen if you're a
male out there if you identify as a male
you're a biblical listening right now
according to these stats are having this
issue and we're giving you a quick way
to solve stuff go to k-e-e-p
dot com that's keeps.com k-e-e-p-s dot
com slash hey babe to receive your first
month of treatment for free that's
k-e-e-p-s dot com hey babe get your
first month free even if you don't have
hair loss why not it's free try it out
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash hey babe we got
whippets
no that was me though whippets i know
there was a story yeah there was this
i have i have a i have a two things to
toss up but i was something else
i know we can tell
but you were pretty emotional about
whippets when we were talking about
before the show started yeah okay so
this weekend i went to this weekend yeah
this weekend i went to brooklyn steel to
see the flaming list no no you're
[ __ ]
absolute degenerate it was mid-week oh
you didn't do weekend
you're preceding the story the whippets
are the whip it's all the reveal
oh i knew you didn't know that i didn't
know that that's right no no but i just
i just want to say
though days of the week mean nothing to
me for the last 10 years which is the
most beautiful part about having korean
entertainment is literally days of the
week are meaningless but then you also
lose the feel that everyone else has on
the weekend special the weekend is
actually when things don't happen yeah
yeah when they're like ah everything
what am i gonna do it's like on friday
yeah monday's like the fire department
was the same thing really i would work
two 24-hour shifts a week then i'd be
off the rest of the five days a week
yeah and it was just like oh [ __ ] yeah
what a great way to live yeah it's
awesome long story short
uh six of us we go to see the flaming
lips show's great uh wonderful i've seen
them in the past this might have been my
favorite time seeing them they always
put on a crazy stage show it's one that
you dropping edible for for sure you got
to do it we're having a couple drinks
nothing crazy we went out for drinks and
a bite beforehand by the time the show
ended you know i had had a few drinks
and inedible feeling nice
we go to leave we're gonna go to
actually actually we didn't eat we just
drank we had popcorn at the boston and
we were going to a diner afterward so
we're outside the place it's all letting
out we're trying to decide where to go
so we're just standing against a brick
wall by brooklyn steel and we're
laughing and talking and we're all a
little tipsy right and we saw someone
else we knew that i haven't seen in like
10 years a friend of ours and i was like
oh my god she was introducing us to who
she knew so it's a little bit of chaotic
right
and then somebody just hands me a
balloon
and uh it's a blown-up balloon was it my
aunt why was it my aunt yeah yeah yeah
your iran emerged from the shadow yeah
i'm just talking and someone hands me a
balloon but it's someone i was with i
think i don't even know i don't even
know who handed me the balloon yeah but
it was it was a regular like balloon
that you like blow up and it was pretty
big it was like that and i just thought
that like they were passing around
balloons because many times at a at the
show they'll drop confetti balloons i
just thought it was
i thought it was just a random balloon
right and i was talking to someone i
wanted to laugh so i take the balloon i
suck it in and i'm thinking i'm going to
talk and go hey
with the helium so i go and i go you
know
and it's like my regular voice and i was
like what i was like all right
and i was like you know and i was like
oh like um
nothing's like nothing's happening like
i guess this one didn't have helium in
it i'm just sucking in someone's breath
you know because it wasn't floating i
was like oh no you know but i sucked in
most of the balloon
that was the end of it right and then i
looked and everybody was sucking on the
balloons all of a sudden everybody was
sucking on balloons i didn't think
anything because i was already a little
tipsy now after i sucked the balloon i
started getting even more tipsy and i
just thought everything was just gang
like just the funniest i don't know what
it was we go to the diner i barely
remember the diner i come home we're
coming home i'm like what's going on and
then someone goes yeah well we all had
that nitrous oxide
and i said what are you talking about
they're like the balloons they were
filled with nitrous oxide i was like did
anyone know this they're like everybody
was doing it and i was like i didn't
know that was nitrous oxide i thought i
was sucking in helium like no and i'm
like is that why i'm feeling this way
like yeah yeah and i'm like i had no
freaking idea now i go
where did all these balloons fill with
nitrous oxide come from they're like
there was a guy selling them i go we
bought the balloons yeah they go someone
bought them yeah it was like five four
uh four for 20. yeah because didn't you
notice it wasn't hearing when your voice
didn't change that i did but i just
thought that i was just sucking in a
balloon someone blew up right and i was
like oh i'm sucking in someone's air
right i didn't know it was
just laughing gas or whatever the [ __ ]
it is i don't think i've ever done
nitrous oxide either and so i didn't
find out too late and everybody else
knew and they would look at me like you
didn't know that that's what we were
doing i was like is that why
you guys well they were laughing on the
com on the cement on the floor
so hard that they couldn't speak
but i didn't suck the whole balloon but
like they did and i was like man we're
having a blast tonight
i'm a real funny guy people love me i
love that in the beginning of the
pandemic if we even went near another
human being sounds like you can't give
up my house for 14 days now he's sucking
random balloon air from strangers in the
middle of a dance floor
i love how it's all changed no it's
almost definitely a mistake but it was
if i was of sound in mind a good sound
of mind i wouldn't have done that but
again i in my head it was just blown up
helium
like not someone's breath you know it
was just a blown up helium balloon so i
didn't think anything of it at all i
thought it was going to be a good time
charlie and talk with the voice and then
uh and then um you know and then they
told me a guy was out there selling them
and i'm thinking to myself this guy has
a merch he's he's standing outside how
brazen can you that has to be illegal
you can't sell nitric oxide
he's selling balloons five dollars a pop
handing out the whole place is sucking
down balloons and this guy is out there
there's crowd control there with
security this guy's out there like he's
like it's that like a pop-up at yankee
stadium like he's selling merch yeah wow
wild right another reason i had no clue
it would be that because who in their
right mind would think that there's a
guy out there yeah selling drugs viable
yeah yeah i'm balloons laced with
fentanyl here we go
to do before our live shows yeah just
get the audience ready
is it dangerous yeah so i used to go to
old boys school and everyone would do
whippets in class we all went to an
all-boys school oh yeah
we're all boys survivors so i was
obsessed with the side effects of
whippets and you can have an instant
aneurysm
oh there you go there's like a one in
you know it's pretty but what was that
like because whippets back in the day
weren't not just nitrous oxide
well the kids in my school were using
keyboard cleaner yeah that's what i mean
i i
guess
yeah that could cause problems because
i've been to the dentist and got they
just mix it with oxygen right at the
dentist when you get the nitrous oxide i
think so it's a little watered down yeah
but it's you know got to be safe oh my
god you're a second keyboard cleaner i
would watch them do it in history class
and then their eyes they would pass out
they'd throw up they'd take their shirt
did you ever suck keyboard cleaner hell
no no i wanted one of them i was rooting
for the worst
[Laughter]
no i i always thought people did it with
like the whipped cream
yeah that's what i always heard too yeah
you can get a lot there's a lot of
problems but they were like you just get
light because people have done it i go
have you ever done it they go yeah like
and they would like to with the ready
web shout out ready whip by the way
if you'd like to sponsor the show we're
big fans yeah [ __ ] cool just like oh you
get lightheaded for a little bit it
lasts a few seconds that's it meanwhile
back at the ranch you can get an
aneurysm yeah oh yeah all vitamin b12
deficiency delusions hallucinations
damage to the peripheral spinal cord
disease you don't want imagine you get
spinal cord disease from ready whip you
don't want that that's a stupid way to
go you don't want that you guys are
listening out there kids don't do it
don't do it
do not do it i know it's fun you know
what you're better off eating a tide pod
you would think that we wouldn't have to
do a public service announcement on not
taking balloons from strangers
and just sucking whatever's inside them
but apparently we have to because people
will do all my friends will do it
i felt duped
yeah yeah did you have a hangover the
next day for a minute was there uh
yeah i don't know if it's from the
whip-it but or whatever it was but well
you wouldn't have to write his room yeah
yeah i know he's probably got some good
bits though that day right
yeah not better not bad we got pretty
good because they said they say like
there's that old i don't know if it's
true or not where like uh lauren
michaels will lock the snl riders in
there till like four o'clock in the
morning and get their brains so fatigued
and then that's when they like that's
what they say but i guess he's not on
whippets yeah
well they are even worse
yeah you think saturday live is like it
used to be where it used to be coke
everywhere because like you hear the old
you just can't right cocaine is making a
humongous comeback though for a while
cocaine like even when i was growing up
the same pr team as kale yep cocaine
cocaine i don't know who they got for p
yeah cocaine is now all the kids want to
do coke again all like it's like cool
and fun to do like no but it's not but
yeah no i'm saying don't do it but now
19 20 year olds are doing coconut when i
was 19 20 no it's like
it's called fentanyl now that's what it
is yeah yeah
don't do it if you're listening to your
kid don't you will blow you'll die
cocaine no i didn't want to ask you i've
sell this yeah was there any any bits on
jokers that got deleted that you loved
very few got deleted yeah i told them
the story of the one with the kids in
the park yeah that that we didn't love
that one anyway and the one with the
mimes there's like two of them yeah they
they only get to leave because they bomb
not because although i to be honest the
the mime one
was i fought for and nobody wanted to do
it i was like guys trust me it's gonna
be [ __ ] great and we did it it
flopped but it flops because it was 101
degrees that day yeah and we were in the
makeup it was getting in our eyes and we
were sweating and everything hurt so i
still think it has an opportunity to
succeed the mind no no no no i think
another part was we couldn't even speak
no it's a good bit listen to me here's
the bit you're mine we just went out and
there was no silence no no no no no no
no did you consist
this is what i'm saying we were by
bethesda fountain right and we were
mimes and you had to go up to people and
we held up what you had to mime to
people and and to get them to see and
they had to guess what you were miming
so think about that so you so whatever
it is
but you can't speak but you're sitting
there whatever pick the worst example
jerk off you know what i mean like the
worst example we would never do it on
the show but you know you have to be
sitting there and going like this and
are you jerking off there's gold there
there's gold there but not in 101 degree
weather this is not golden
temperature is what made the beach i
know the temperature because all your
[ __ ] were talking about it's so
hot it's in my eyes it's in my eyes
i got no support
yeah
you know how many [ __ ] [ __ ] i support
on that show that i'm like i don't know
about this that day they failed me my
teammates failed me completely is that
why they strapped a mime to you
no that was that was just my turn in the
background he loves mine you got one of
you was really on mine that might have
been why you guys came up with that i
don't know that yeah pierre that was
good but yeah i still think that one
could work why it's still a good bid
the mime right it's a good bit we we we
we chained the mind to him and then
sometimes we create a universe of
characters on the show we have like a
ton of them and a lot of times we'll do
something like the cruise we'll have
them we'll put them on the cruise so
they walk around it's almost like it's a
universe the characters right yeah right
yeah
i'm great dude really nice guy he really
he really commits like when he was a
classically trained mind he went to like
france mine like marcel marcotte yeah
you're not you didn't you don't just
call his name for real as pierre the
mind
well his name's peter but but yeah he's
his business name
yeah okay great guy hard worker so we
strapped into him that guy did not we
met him and he did not speak the morning
after when we had to unchain him from
him and walk out of the hotel and and
they said all right we did it and we
untied it and like all right we got it
we're done he took over and he was like
hey thanks guys
he didn't speak the entire left in bed
with this man i took a [ __ ] chain to
this man i never heard his voice
until he did it he committed and he was
never in a bad mood
he was in character of 24 hours it was
nuts yeah it was admirable it was
actually infuriating as well
because you just like couldn't piss him
off just talk to it yeah yeah but he was
on and i don't know the circumstances
trying to eat fries like the cameras
weren't even on that was the thing oh he
wouldn't stop him the cameras weren't
always like andy kaufman yeah so like we
would go we would go to dinner the crew
broke for the day we went to dinner and
i'm trying to eat fries and he's putting
his fingers in my fries flipping them on
the table and i'm like dude we're not
shooting right now you could [ __ ] not
do this and he would not stop actually
the kardashians uh he was on that
contacted us what and said or they on
their show they were like oh did you see
that episode of impractical jokers with
the mime and they were like again they
were like let's do that on our show and
they got the same mind yeah they got
pierre the money yeah i don't remember
the context of why they got it what's
cool about it
they they asked permission actually he
he called and he was like do you mind if
i do what i was like you [ __ ]
yeah do you mind if i get chained to kim
kardashian
he gets changed where he's like so i'm
supposed to not talk
just immediately ruins the bed on the
cruise i don't i don't remember the
circumstances i'm gonna say everything's
alleged because i don't but i think that
he he
pushed he
a girl walked one way and he went the
other way as a joke and he like pulled
her arm out of the socket or something
like that
oh no she fell down the steps and broke
her foot what she broke up she won a
wheelchair she's like piano she broke
her toe or something and they sued no
they they sued i forgot how that got
settled but but then peter called me
he's like he repeat he was like he was
like what am i gonna do he's like i was
like we're not going to hang out the
drive we're like obviously
if someone's going after you personally
like we'll back you up like oh
he couldn't stop talking yeah
they was trying to get me on the hook
and then i think they settled you guys
are out here saving mimes saving money
what was your least favorite day of
being an impractical joker
oh man
i we don't even it's been a decade uh
yeah there's the morning universal
studios where we shot the bit you know
the tram ride through universal where
it's like a 45-minute tour yeah and you
go by the psycho house and they did a
bit with me where uh i had to pull the
emergency stop and uh and i had to do it
like seven times
in a 45-minute ride the ride went
to an hour and like almost two hours and
people were [ __ ] pissed people were
like you're rooney like the first time
whatever all right [ __ ] [ __ ]
second time the third time people hated
me and i still had an hour to go and it
was like it was concentrated hate yeah
they started physically threatening you
yeah one guy one guy stands up and none
of them were joking and he goes when
this is over he goes when we get off
this i'm gonna [ __ ] find you he's
like you ruined you know how much money
i paid for this vacation you're [ __ ]
ruining it and it was like i've never it
was like just concentrated hate for so
long that the guy i [ __ ] with my head
i bet man like
i'm nervous even just hearing you yeah
it took a day or two because the people
next to you
can't
you know they're not going to be like
[ __ ] you mother you know what i mean but
they still hate you so it's so they're
not as aggressive about it but they're
like
like doing [ __ ] like that and like
sighing and stuff and like and you're
just like man yeah when you're getting
all that energy focused on you and you
know you got to keep doing it it's tough
yeah it's tough fun to watch that was a
rough one yeah did i ever tell you the
story about
on another cruise story i think it was
the first cruise ever we do these my
friends uh shout out chris goldteath and
lord easy my friends kristen joel chris
gold teeth yeah i love it great name
gold and lordy kristen joel they do this
they have this karaoke killed the cat
they're these karaoke hoes oh yeah
though i saw those guys on the cruise
yeah they're great those are great
they used to i met them a long time ago
and we've done a lot of great parties
together and they always do the cruise
and it's like the highlight of the
cruise like scythe's coming out and
djing and it's singing it's crazy it's a
they the way they do this dan this thing
is like it's always a crazy
party like a dance party like people
jumping up like it's it's just
everyone's involved no one's scared to
sing full-on support and it becomes this
like it's almost like um goddamn comedy
jam you know yeah
so
i've like people stage dive during it
and stuff so my friend like it was a you
know at a height in the night right and
he
he everyone's feeling it i think they
were in booty shorts like it's just
funny like it's like it was a [ __ ]
party they might have been in ski max
and booty shorts like the guy it's fun
it's just fun and funny and everyone's
just going nuts and so my friend we're
all on stage and i see it in his eyes
and my buddy chris he just goes and he's
like i'm gonna do and he just runs and
jumps in he's probably like my frame
he goes he leaps in the air and into the
crowd and he's in mid air and the crap
he's not a small guy he's like he's my
frame and the crowd
moves out of the way oh my god
except for one person a girl
with crutches
and they all move out of the way and he
legitimately like jimmy superfly snooker
lands 100
only on her the crutches shot up and
spun like you saw the entire i was
watching the whole thing i watched him
move it was like slow motion he lands on
her the crutches shoot both ways in
every direction he flattens her like a
pancake
she broke his fall he didn't realize in
his adrenaline and because she broke his
fall he stands up and he's like yeah
and he's singing and he's standing above
her
she looks like in the cartoon when
someone gets run over to steamroll and
one legs one way
and he's just like yeah you know like
sit stupid
and everyone's like oh my god and they
rush to pick her up and everything and
he just runs through the crowd and he
has no idea and then he gets back up and
like oh my god dude you've pancaked this
woman in crutches you pancaked this
already crippled woman i know we fought
because she and she was so sweet about
it oh we we know she's like a mega fan
like we seriously feel very supportive
and she was like yeah i i've you know
i've been on crutches for a while and i
haven't been able to do anything social
and the cruise was my first pledge to
myself to go out and be social again
and you know and and then so we heard
this and we were like
oh my god it was like an accident but so
we actually ended up you know meeting
with her yeah and hanging out with her a
bit and talking to her because you know
i don't know you know you know i don't
know she was such a good sport about it
but i don't know the rules there when
someone just really like yeah yeah you
come out your first day out you get
pancaked by gold teeth
you got to be careful on those cruises
yeah i woke up the next morning and i
heard the story and i was like well
we're going down for that one yeah you
were like yeah
we thought she was gonna own yeah you
guys like hey it was nice it was nice
having the show but it's over it's gonna
be like cold like pam's royal caribbean
cruise and then one what wasn't our
cruise but i woke up the next morning
where was it where i got up and i you
know i went to breakfast and they're
like yeah we got into a brawl on the
cruise like sal cold [ __ ] some
[ __ ] in the middle of the dance
floor and i was like you punched it
i was like what do you mean they're like
no sal this is the way it was described
to me sal with full weight went back and
[ __ ] jammed some guy in his face and
and sent them down and then the whole
crew like jumped like the ij they're
like family to us the crew and it was
just like like a [ __ ] pier six brawl
like as you say yeah and and i was like
what the [ __ ] happens after i go to
sleep at night on these cruise days
cruise though this was we filmed an
episode on the cruise
and that's how they offered us the
cruise and we had four cruises after
that but when we went on this cruise we
weren't allowed to walk around because
they weren't allowed to know we were on
it so we were like stowaways for like
five days and we would just come out and
film something and go away again
and it was like a sucker it was like
yeah it was like one of the last nights
and um
and uh yeah there was just there was
these pack of drunk [ __ ] bothering
people on our crew and they were like
they were like messing with got a little
bit and messing with dan cast oh you
don't [ __ ] with dan kennedy and dan cass
is he's our first ada and he's like he's
the best ever and and uh you know i i'm
not like a tough guy anything i was
probably drinking too and i just
gathered is not someone that
like would fight ever and dan cass is
like the most beloved person but neither
are you
yeah yeah you don't show not when
someone's [ __ ] with someone like i
know or something i'll i'll i'll
i'm not violent i don't fight i can't
fight but like in that scenario like
just enraged
yeah yeah and i saw like something about
to go down and someone shoved someone
first okay and and i saw it and i just
was like i'm not gonna let this happen
and i just i i i just i grabbed the guy
who shoved someone by the back and i got
him in like a chokehold and i didn't
want to like hurt anybody but i just and
i took him and i just threw him with all
my weight like almost a clothesline down
wow and then some guy kate was coming at
me and so i just punched him oh my god
did he go down there i i don't remember
but that's what i told her i heard it
was like i threw this one down and then
and then
i so much it was almost like a mosh pit
i was getting like banged around and
then i don't know i just for some reason
i think i covered up because it was like
mayhem and i just felt someone grabbed
me and that sounds like the sal i know
i kept feeling people hitting me but it
wasn't like it didn't hurt but i kept
feeling like
people hit it and i just got i literally
got taken like and and i felt my whole
body and then when i like when i like
when they kind of like were done
swooping me away i kind of like what
came up and i looked and it was pete
mcpartland and he just gra
our showrunner actually and uh and
friend for like 15 years and he just got
me out of there and like he was like all
right we'll just everyone just dispersed
and uh i don't really know what happened
it was like one of those things in the
moment where everything happened so
quick
but yeah we definitely they hit me i hit
people i don't get a lot of fights but
and then we thought people are going to
be a lot of trouble but it just
dispersed i guess this fight sometimes
nothing happened but after breaking it
up they closed down the whole night they
shut turned up the light shut the music
off and they were trying to get people
to go back to their rooms and the three
of these kids that were starting to
fight one in the night they're down
we're just literally lurking following
us waiting to fight again wow but
ultimately nothing happens that's why
they were there probably to fight to
fight well who pays that money on the
cruise though
it didn't make sense to me like we
didn't start the trouble they did but i
was like what is going on we're on a
[ __ ] vacation
yeah wow well i do have one more
question while we have you two here yeah
who do you think got it worst on a
practical jokers the whole run punish
the worst oh well sal i mean he got the
most of him
out of me and him no out of all four
would you say me though well you just in
quantity
i've been punished the most yeah yeah i
lost the most okay so in quantity by a
big number or is it like uh
i don't think it's like neck and neck
it's probably a little bit more i don't
think it's like it's double yeah i think
it's you and murray are like account for
like 60 of them there's like someone had
a count on wikipedia now i don't know
what it is i think i think it's because
they always make you say the worst thing
possible it's because he's funny to
punish man like he wears it on his face
and stuff okay but as far as like we
love doing it the worst punishments i
think probably murray has gotten the
worst punishments i mean in the movie
when he got strapped to the plane yeah
that was one of those things where i was
like
yeah i don't know i think i would i
understand it's lively fun though really
that's why i don't think that's a bad
one i mean it's it's for him it's bad
but people do it for fun but like yeah
you have to be a person who's able to do
that otherwise you just literally one
buckle you're dead yeah like immediately
we were hoping
people who haven't seen it you know
those planes like like the red baron
like people like a biplane so you know
you sit in it and it's like outdoors
like you know you're it's open and it's
and so murray had to in midair get out
of his seat
crawl to the front of the plane climb up
to the top wing
and buckle him oh he was already buckled
he was buckled every time you know he
was strapped but when he got up there he
strapped himself to a pole yeah that was
on the top of the stand though but he's
still in a buckle on himself sure he was
always
quote-unquote safe but yeah but it's
terrifying
but he had he was tethered
but he still had the slack was there he
still had to get out of his seat crawl
to the front of the plane while it was
in the air
i feel this in my ass climbing right now
get on and then strap himself in and
then the plane flew for like 15 minutes
and it was going and he was standing
outside the top of a plane it was wide i
mean that's scary but having to see
jayden smith on my body forever
that's a long time but murray's had uh
i mean they put like metal in his penis
yeah
yeah we probed his penis yeah it's like
we had him get a oh we got him get a
what do you call that
we had to have to keep reshooting
because he kept coming
that was actually
very recent very recently so here's what
we did we put a tube in his penis and we
blew up the tube like what's that
medical thing catheter catheter we put
the catheter in with the with the with
the balloon and we put it in and we had
a doctor do it and it was at his house
and we blew it up and then we said he
has a
we blew it up and now he's going to got
him to dress back so he has the catheter
in him and it's
blown up so it's very uncomfortable he
came over hurts and then we put him on a
zip line
and then he zip lined and then at the
end it like jerks and he was like oh my
god oh my god
i love the escalation of the show
then we brought it back
is it nursing is a nurse yeah or a
nursing student or nurse she comes out a
nurse outfit and she takes it out she
had to take it out of his penis on
camera oh my god and then
it's one man
it was funny he's intense
like saying stuff like i will now we
told him to speak medical terms but keep
insulting murray so he kept going i will
now err i will now insert the catheter
into his average-sized penis
below average
venus because i will now insert this
into a below average penalty and
suddenly that's the worst part of the
punishment for murray he's like it's not
it's that below average
and then as soon as he pulled it out and
murray's like oh
and then we're like well was that
because one time on the show we made him
get a um
prostate exam that was great so the
doctor had to do it and then we got
another doctor to come and do his second
opinion well he did it twice for a
second opinion we wanted to go for a
third opinion they we that's a bad like
something that day it's a battle we lost
that i always wish we got anyway so we
said to him so was the catheter worse
than the prostate exam and he's like i
don't know what he said and then as soon
as we said that the doctor who gave him
the prostate exam he didn't know was
hiding behind a wall and he popped out
with a glove and he snapped he snapped
it he goes did somebody say prostate
exam and then he goes in and gives more
your prostate
oh my god you hammered both holes
has there ever been a punishment where
you guys were like you had to convince
the guy to do it like oh yes
where they were adamant like i will not
do this i'll quit the show yeah but then
they wind up doing it right how'd the
pitch about the catheter go was he
he didn't know he was like yeah he's on
a board but he's a good sport about
stuff that's what i'm saying he does
stuff that
yeah he takes it hard he he didn't he
didn't want to jump out of a plane we
convinced him he lost he actually cried
he was crying he was crying yeah he was
crying he called his mom and he's like
if i do this i don't know what's going
to happen yeah yeah
if he wasn't going to do it i would have
had to do it i love that that shows
torture for all of you yeah it is it can
be we wrapped season five on the
punishment where i had tarantulas put on
me and it was the last day shooting was
the last thing and it was i i that was
one they had to talk me into i was like
i don't think i can do this i was like i
don't think i can do something like he's
just like i'm not that bad of spiders
i'm okay with but something about
tarantulas just click something in my
lizard brain and uh it was it felt like
torture and then we wrapped and
three guys just had you guys for
whatever reason somebody had to catch a
flight somebody but they left i stuck
around to have like a set of a
half-assed wrap party with a crew and
the crew was like like al came up with
me he's like
he's like dude for the first time in the
show he's like i didn't think it was
funny he goes it looked like we were
torturing you and i was like yeah if you
look at the clip we are it is it's like
it was bad like my muscles hurt the next
day because i was just so tense and [ __ ]
like that
yeah so it can get you know it could get
hairy on that show but what are you
gonna do that's what you signed up for i
get like that anything heights my whole
body freezes up and tenses up and then i
don't like haunted houses they throw me
in like a haunted corn field and they
another time they got a [ __ ] like i
guess like a mansion or something or a
big big home yeah i don't know even
where in the middle of nowhere it's
upstairs and they made
the house haunted and they locked me in
it and how long i had to walk through
the whole house in every room they had
something to put something in every room
and i actually uh was so
the little girl the little girl was
crazy yeah my adrenaline was
so hot look i know it i know exactly
what's going on i just don't like jump
scares no who doesn't there was a jump
and the whole thing was about jump
scares and it was 20 minutes straight
you know including the very end where
someone chased me and i ran out i
remember when i ran out of that i had
a splitting migraine headache for like
an hour after that because the just the
adrenaline rush of keeping like having
to get scared over and over i'm starting
to wonder how many years of your life
are shaved off
yeah i mean we're not as bad as we're
not as bad as the jackass guys but we
get beat up like i had broken ribs i
would never do something
yeah you had broken ribs murray had got
that messed up bad yeah yeah it happens
yeah but you know what though we've
changed like i i we've started to accept
that we're older and that we're not
really doing things like that anymore
it's just too hard oh you just started
stuffed in metal running
i said i said we're not doing things
like that
you know what happens
we decided to do the 200th episode live
at the barclays center and we did it in
in tandem with uh travis travis
bickelbach travis travis barker no the
uh most nitrous certificate circus uh oh
travis pastrana
yeah sorry travis
those guys are all great so we go up to
his compound to train for it and the
whole thing is is that we are all going
to compete in an obstacle course
and it's live and it's it's and it's and
it's like it's riding quads it's like
rope jumping it's like it's like all
this stuff like running up a hill
swinging on a thing and uh you know
we're not like that you know and one of
it was going to be that we had to be on
the motorcycle while they were doing
flips
so we go up to the compound in maryland
we go up to the compound in maryland we
were on the road we diverted there
we're with them for like a day or
something yeah or two and the whole goal
there was to get used to doing flips on
the motorcycle which was atv
it was a four it was a quad no no that
was to get that there was two things we
did we got on quads and rode their whole
dirt paths up down mountains that's what
i got hurt on yes that's how you fell
off and cracked your ribs
but the loser of the day was going to
have to be on the back seat of a
motorcycle that did a ramp into the air
at the barclays and that did a flip and
landed again and so we didn't know who
was going to lose but the idea was
remember they were doing the flips and
landing in that foam
you don't remember this well because
once i broke my ribbed i'm out of all
that
my experience was a little different oh
so you didn't i went to the hospital
from the thing you didn't see them doing
the the practice flips no
oh my god okay so you oh wait wait yeah
they were doing it into like a foam
square yeah i did see that you're right
like like like the olymp like the actual
yeah like
so but it was a picture like a like like
a that foam square it's picture it
15 feet high
off the ground and maybe like
10 15 feet wide and maybe like maybe
like
40 feet long it's like an olympic
swimming pool yeah and they're going off
these ramps the ramps that like you know
when the skiers go and they're just like
yeah it's those type of ramps and they
go
and they're doing flips and they fall in
the foam with the bike and everything
they just go right to the bottom and
everyone jumps in and goes and gets them
and that's how they practice
so or at least that's how they practice
there so the the thing is they're
showing us like it's gonna be no problem
you'll see us we'll do it you we we do
this they were like we all do this we've
all jumped a thousand times each you
know we've all we're professionals you
know
we're gonna we're gonna show you how we
do it into the phone
and then you know when when you're ready
you guys will sit you know behind one of
us holding us and we'll do it with you
and all you got to do is just keep stay
down hold the thing and don't move and
let it guide you we promise it'll be
okay and we're like all right like
we wanted to make a good 200 live
episode but it was like
also like i don't know if i could bring
myself to do this so they're like we'll
show you
and i don't know if you know johnny
knoxville broke his urethra on that show
nitro no i didn't know that yeah oh my
god you were
so
yeah so so they start showing us with
another guy doing it and they go they
flip off and they crash
they go they flip the guy falls off they
go they flip the guy gets separated
their bike almost falls on top of them
they go they flip they they go like out
of the way a little bit and they're like
[ __ ] man and they were just like this
never happens
and we were just like yeah
uh we're not doing that yeah and they
were like uh understandable and so then
what happened was
we murray ended up losing and he had to
stand on the ramp like a foot like a two
feet before they landed
he had to stand there i think we tied
him up
and they did the flip and then the bike
was coming right at him and went right
over his head and he had to endure like
them doing that for like a few minutes
scary [ __ ] but anyway yeah and then we
did the we so we go to do this live
thing now we now we're at the barclays
practicing yeah do you remember i broke
my [ __ ] foot i cracked my foot so bad
it was purple and bleeding we almost all
died there yeah joe almost had a heart
attack you had to jump on a [ __ ] you
had to jump on a trampoline and catapult
through this like wall or whatever and
in the in the practice
and then oh i lost too because you
struggled to do the cake thing right
yeah so i guess i lost oh we both lost
murray one because remember how [ __ ]
no but he he was the one that had to be
over he lost the episode but the the
obstacle course he won okay yeah i no
but i didn't lose the obstacle course
joe did i don't know
joe actually had a seizure live on
television joe is so out of shape that
he got
he got it he got halfway through he got
halfway through the ocelot and he jumped
and he was in a super man outfit a
captain fat
creation so he was in a cape in his
underwear
and he got winded halfway through and at
the part that i hurt myself you jump on
a trampoline and then you you there's
three doors three two are real doors and
one and one is like a fake door and they
had our faces on them but you can't tell
which one's real it's not like you look
real and you have to
guess you have to jump through and so
you run up a ramp and you have to go
airborne and jump through a door and if
it's the real door you just slam against
the door
and you just fall down like you wail
against a real door you jump and you
just go and you hit it like a cartoon
and you're slowing down
to that part and he's already winded and
he's running
right right
his face looks like a [ __ ] canned ham
it's sweaty it's pink that cape's behind
his head he's in his other way he looks
winded he gets up and he's live he's
live and he runs it right he jumps in he
goes
and then everyone's waiting and he never
comes out no no no no that's not true he
had to do it again remember he guessed
wrong the second time he goes he does
the wind-up
obstacle course so if you hit the wrong
thing it's almost like ninja warrior you
have to run back around and do it again
until you get through oh my god
he goes to the second hell
we we're dying
eight thousand people that the whole
crowd's like
it's
he was he was having like his body was
convulsive
commercial things
shut down
his body shut down one of the time on
the tv what he did that when he did the
uh the the uh olympic of the soccer
soccer team the olympic routine remember
the uk he did as well
he had to do an olympic routine and he
went full bore and he didn't have the
stamina and he said he said as he
started to black out he thought he's
gonna pass out at the end of it and then
his whole body felt like jello and then
he couldn't breathe so this is what
happened so he's laying on the floor
medics russian live television
and they're like we got to cut the
commercial and we just cut the
commercial we we didn't even anticipate
that he didn't finish the obstacle
course amazing he got pulled and he
literally they had to put him like on
oxygen stuff and then i in the practice
round i jumped on the trampoline and my
foot got caught between a metal bar when
i landed and my foot just snapped my big
toe
i was like oh oh they took off my shoe
my shoe my this big thing was purple it
was bleeding it was cut open my whole
foot you know when you get instant
purple yeah the whole foot turned purple
they sent me to the hospital
and they i'm in the hospital they give
me pain medication they they bandage it
up thick and they put my shoe back on
because i was like we have a live
200 i have to still do it
so i then i went and did it hopped up on
like the pain meds and i did it with the
broken foot and then at the end they put
me in a i don't know why that was me oh
we let the the audience vote who they
want
they voted
it was it was a live tally the whole
time and then they voted me and since
i'm scared of heights they they clicked
me onto a cable pulled me up to the
ceiling of watercolors i love it and
that was it was a prudential a
prudential potential and they had a
sheet cake it was like a 15-foot sheet
cake upright without congratulations on
your 200 episode and from one end of the
prudential center to the other they let
the thing go and on a rope i swung in
the air across the whole thing and then
just slammed into the cake at the end
that's pretty awesome i love that this
is your job just real quick the one
other time gatto we were in uh the uk we
did a uk episode and we went to the
wickham warriors which by the way shout
out wikimores shout out to uk they were
amazing we they let them have our
let us have this soccer stadium and then
they filled it like thousands of people
from the uk came and filled the stands
and joe and murray lost and they had to
be goaltenders and the entire
professional soccer team was just
wailing
like a whaling balls at them yeah the
place is going nuts and eventually like
you get hit with so many of those i
think joe got hit in the face and he
went down and then when we called it the
team
yeah and they did a pile on joe was on
the bottom it was like 20 men
and joe was on the bottom and no one
knew like he he was free he was actually
like in bad bad pain he couldn't breathe
he was screaming and he was like it was
like on the bottom of a stampede yeah
yeah
and and they all got up one by one by
one and then when they all got up joe
was the reveal joe was the last person
he was face down like mushed into the
grass
they had to get the medics they put him
on like a sh they didn't carry him
he couldn't he asked him to move he said
i cannot move we got so nervous he goes
i can't feel my legs my toes i can't
move we were like is he like paralyzed
even he couldn't move they had to get
his adult body again he was assaulted
him he was pink he couldn't breathe they
brought him and we had to get on a but
we had to get on a car to get on a
flight in like an hour we had to for the
next show in the uk and they brought him
into the trainer's room all the medics
came in and they had to lay him on his
side because his back was like
whack they had to take his shirt off and
they had all medics working on him and
he couldn't move for like 10 15 minutes
yeah and he was just he was intense and
then he made it then he finally made a
joke and we were like oh thank you oh my
god i actually like you know how my
friends took pictures of me when i fell
in the skeleton yeah i i mean i felt
truly bad at first but then also i
started videotaping it and taking
pictures i have that
and you know
at a certain point though you had to
give in to that it was also funny so i
felt bad but we were dying dude and he
he
you know joe's never serious
so when he's in pain seriously for some
reason it's funny because that's not his
demeanor and so when he's laying on the
floor being like i don't think i'm going
to make it or whatever it's so funny
yeah we never talk jokers on this show
but it's a lot of funny stories i guess
i love it all right all right well yeah
we're going on tour
christy county dot com savannah dot com
you know this by now but the week from
christmas to new year's it's uh texas
missouri and ohio uh i'm in boston on
the 10th i'm in atlantic city new jersey
on the 11th and the west palm on the
december 4th to 5th and you go there you
go yep i'm in phoenix december 2nd to
the 4th west palm december 17th to 18th
we got the beacon theater on sale in
february borgata january 29th um las
vegas at the win march 25th uh and also
shout out tom brady congratulations you
you know super bowl winner in your
hometown in tampa and you can't we can't
end there i'd be remiss if i didn't say
congratulations to the kansas city
chiefs and patrick holmes giving a good
college try gorgeous now anything
tell him steve dave anything you're like
actually queue's about to celebrate his
500th episode of his podcast wow
we've been doing it 12 12 years now wow
original it's gonna be pretty good oh
gee a lot of you guys that watch me
probably know me from their podcast uh
so if you don't though tell them we
started doing television dave i had to
explain to people what a podcast was how
long ago it was explained it to me yeah
i didn't understand it yeah i'd be like
it's like a radio show but it's on the
internet no nobody knew what i said to
you i remember what i said i said but
why
do people want to hear what i have to
say i don't understand 500 episodes have
you missed one week no no we we've
missed we probably miss about four weeks
maybe even more but that's we have
special episodes that's not counted in
that we did we did the first ever
podcast episode on vinyl we were the
first ones that ever did that yeah wow
uh so we have like we probably in
reality have closer to like
550 560 episodes official episodes isn't
that wild amazing
yeah yeah well look this was oh and i'll
be at the uh i'll be your show on the
11th oh yeah yeah i won't be on stage
but i'm coming to the show yeah look at
this atlantic city new jersey
you're coming on stage
and actually i don't want to i won't
tease it but someone else told me they
were going to come and come on stage and
if you're a listener i think you'll like
it very much bon jovi there you go
atlantic city december 11th q will be
there special guest come on now this was
awesome i had so much great absolutely a
lot of fun guys thank you so much no
dude thank you
i love having you come back anytime
we're gonna go to the old west we're
gonna do that wild west new jersey we
gotta go we're going all right this is
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe